[Musique]
c'est en noir et blanc et en
photographie qu'Élisabeth oo se projette
dans son art quand elle entend parler du
prix seliman elle se dit pourquoi ne pas
tenter sa chance trois clichés en noir
et blanc et c'est son travail qui se
retrouve dans tous les journaux
réunionnés j'ai eu la plus grande
surprise de ma vie presque d'avoir ce
coup de téléphone le sort du 8 mars
2005 pour m'annoncer donc j'avais
j'étais le hâte et que j'avais gagné le
premier prix du concours simen une
récompense pour l'auteur des clichés
mais aussi une reconnaissance pour la
photographie cette reconnaissance elle
était non seulement pour pour moi
éventuellement mais pour la photographie
et en noir et blanc surtout parce que à
l'époque et même encore maintenant 10
ans après la photographie en noir ETP
n'est pas nécessairement franchement
reconnue on en voit très peu
d'exposition de ce genre le premier prix
un billet d'avion et un pass lui ouvre
les portes de de Paris les vacances
suivantes j'ai je suis partie à Paris
donc par ce billet d'avion et puis j'ai
pu voilà vivre 8 jours plein avec mon
réflexe mon appareis reféflexe à
l'époque et voilà à saisir des instants
à saisir des gens des regards et et puis
et puis bénéficier aussi de ces de des
pas du Pass pour tous les musées
nationaux qui m'avaient été aussi offert
la suite c'est une autre orientation que
la photographie cette vision du monde
qui qui s'est ouverte un peu plus à moi
cette reconnaissance aussi parce que
quelque part on a aussi besoin d'avoir
un retour un retour des autres du regard
des autres donc c'était important un
priséimen qui lui a permis de mieux se
connaître et d'aborder d'autres
expressions artistiques la sculpture et
la peinture j'ai fait un travail en en
artthérapie pour avancer pour connaître
un peu mes priorités dans la vie quels
étaient les les les angles d'accès ce
qui me correspondait vraiment et à
travers ces différents travaux que j'ai
pu faire en art thérapie ce sont révélé
beaucoup de choses donc j'ai pu
travailler la sculpture la la peinture
Elisabeth qui pratique aussi le yoga a
trouver son équilibre c'est autour des
autres femmes désormais d'oser
s'exprimer d'oser se montrer une
première étape vers une seconde vie
ellisabeth on est
persuadé
[Musique]